avec notre invité benjamin blanchard
directeur général de sos chrétiens
d'orient bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le pape
françois est en train de célébrer sa
première messe publique en irak
pourquoi cette visite pourquoi est-elle
si importante pour le président irakien
et pour le pape françois alors c'est une
visite et qui effectivement très
importante non pas seulement pour le
président irakien mais je crois pour
tout le peuple irakien et également pour
le premier ministre qui puisque là le
personnage principal dans le système
politique irakien c'est le premier
ministre aurait ni s'agit tout
simplement je crois de la première
visite de ce genre pas seulement de
papin mais de n'importe quel chef d'état
depuis l'invasion américaine de 2003 ce
n'est pas une visite surprise une visite
en cachette comme c'est souvent le cas
pour les chefs d'état occidentaux
c'est une visite annoncée longtemps elle
avance depuis trois mois et puis
également une particularité c'est que le
pape se rend vraiment de partout on l'a
vu à les amours on l'a vu aller à nadja
là aujourd'hui il doit se rendre à
mossoul puis après dans la plaine de
ninive
et puis ensuite à erbil qui fait quelque
chose que ni les chefs d'état étrangers
n'en fait depuis 2003 et ni même les
officiels irakiens parce que il faut
dire qu'il ya très peu de visites sur le
terrain du premier ministre des premiers
ministres successifs notamment
donc c'est vraiment très important à la
fois pour l'irak qui peut être fier de
cette visite et surtout si elle va j'en
suis sûr se dérouler correctement sans
problèmes sécuritaires majeurs etc
et puis également pour les chrétiens
puisque ce sont eux qui sont à l'origine
de ce voyage notamment le patriarche des
chaldéens louis raphaël sakho et ce
voyage est en train d'être une grande
réussite donc ça sera un grand atout
pour les chrétiens alors et puis cette
rencontre ce matin on a vu la photo la
vidéo le pape françois avec l'ayatollah
ali sistani la photo et est historique
car mais peu de choses ont filtré de
cette entrevue
quel message cet entretien des vivres
aux tirs c'est un entretien très
important ali sistani est une des
personnalités religieuses chiites les
plus respectées en irak les plus
influentes et il a cette particularité
de défendre un schisme national
patriotique et non pas à fait aux dés
aux puissants voyait deux voisins
iranien essaie il faut savoir que la
communauté chiite est la plus importante
en irak c'est plus de 60% de la
population
donc cette rencontre est un signal fort
pour l'unité de l'irak et pour la place
des chrétiens dans cette unité nationale
alors c'est un des objectifs en vous
l'avez dit de cette visite soutenir les
chrétiens d'orient et quelle est leur
situation actuelle en irak
la situation est très difficile il était
environ un million cinq cent mille en
2003 avant l'invasion américaine
aujourd'hui sont peut-être en d'autres
entre 200 et 300 mille peut être un peu
plus peut-être peut-être encore moi je
n'en sais rien mais en tout cas il ya eu
une forte émigration et c'est bien sûr
une communauté très fragilisé notamment
en raison de la sécurité de miracles do
qui sera tous les irakiens mais qui
touche peut être encore plus les
minorités disent qu'elles sont plus
fragiles
et puis également la corruption et donc
la crise économique qui la conséquence
de cette corruption qui l'a aussi fera
peut-être encore plus les chrétiens en
tant que petite minorité que la majorité
donc le problème est vraiment
démographique est important puisque
cette communauté ne cesse de diminuer en
nombre et en pourcentage
pourquoi la pause des chrétiens en
orient suscitent de vives polémiques
intentions politiques en france
je sais pas si ça suscite de vives
politique en tout cas c'est important
d'un simple point de vue humain puisque
ce sont des gens qui sont chez eux en
irak avant même le christianisme les
populations autochtones aient été là et
donc les populations autochtones se sont
largement converti au christianisme lors
des des premiers temps de l'église et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ils sont encore
toujours présents alors certains de ses
autres tous se sont convertis à l'islam
lors de la conquête arabo islamique
mais pas tous et donc ils ont tout à
fait le droit de vivre sur leurs terres
et puis ensuite il faut dire que c'est
également un facteur de thé très
important pour paul irak et pour
l'ensemble dû proche orient puisque les
chrétiens la particularité de bien vivre
avec tout le monde que ce soit avec les
filles qu'avec les sunnites ou avec les
kurdes
une autre notre peuple et même les
autres minorités musulmanes comme les
druzes ou les alaouites et c'est donc ça
c'est vraiment les chrétiens sont un
vrai facteur de paix alors même que
souvent les communautés musulmanes ont
tendance à se disputer entre elle et on
le voit en irak avec ce conflit
interminable entre sunnites et chiites
depuis 2003 notamment alors vous
reparler de l'ayatollah ali sistani on
l'évoquent
en tout cas on évoque cette personnalité
comme quelqu'un d'ouvert où l'on séparé
la politique de la religion
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
l'interlocuteur idéal pour le pape
mais oui bien sûr que c'est un bon
interlocuteur non seulement du fait de
sa modération et d'éventuels et puis
également du fait de son indépendance ce
n'est pas un pion de l'iran est en fait
c'est une des crashs grand un grand
besoin pour l'irak c'est cette
indépendance
l'irak ne peut pas exister mais les
irakiens ne veulent pas exister en tant
que marionnettes ou des états unis ou de
l'iran ou peut-être des deux à la fois
comme c'est un peu le malheureusement
souvent le cas et on fait une loi y est
là sistani est vraiment le symbole de sa
tendance indépendance nationale et de ce
patriotisme et donc ça va de pair avec
cette modération également donc oui
c'est un excellente interlocuteur pour
le pape et pour n'importe qui en fait en
irak
benjamin blanchard merci à vous je
rappelle qu'on est un directeur général
de sos chrétiens d'orient merci d'avoir
été en direct avec mon sur rt france